exactly as a centroid well centroid is
the point of concurrency where the three
medians in a triangle coincide or
intersect so what's a median well median
goes from the vertex to the middle of
the opposite side so you can see here at
AE see how I've marked these two
segments as being the same they're
congruent because it's the midpoint and
then also look over here BD that's
bisecting AC so these two are congruent
and then you can see CF is going from
the vertex to the middle of you know
that opposite side so bf is congruent to
FA but what's interesting about this
centroid is is that you know each median
is split into two parts
one-third and two-thirds so what I mean
by that is you can see this whole length
here BD Rd would be one-third of the
median length B R would be two-thirds of
that whole median length and the other
thing you want to kind of pay attention
to is that see because Rd is one-third
of the median and BRS two-thirds if you
know Rd you can double that to find B R
or if you know BR you can multiply by
that one by one half to find Rd so let's
go through some examples and you'll see
how this works the other thing that I
want to mention to you real quick is
that sometimes students are wondering
you know if it's not obvious from the
picture which distance is the one third
distance and which is the truthers
distance right well when you're
measuring from the vertex okay so the
corner of the triangle from the vertex
to the centroid that's going to be the
two-thirds part the part from the
opposite side to the centroid that's
going to be the one-third part so here
you can see CR is two-thirds AR is going
to be the two-thirds so from the vertex
to the centroid that's the log or piece
the two-thirds
okay so BD is equal to 27 so that's this
whole link here we want to find out what
the length of BR is and Rd I usually
find the smaller one first because 1/3
is easy to work with you just divide by
3
you take 27 and divide by 3 that's going
to be 9 okay so right here 9 and then B
R is going to be 2/3 of 27 or you can
just double 1/3 to get the 2/3 and
that's going to be 18 and you can see
these two add up to the to the whole
length okay how about F R so FR
they tell us this length is five so that
means we automatically know that CR is
going to be double that's going to be
ten and then of course FC is the whole
length we can add the two pieces
together to get 15
okay now AR is eight so let's look at
this one so AR is eight that's the
two-thirds portion of the median so that
means if we divide that in half our a is
going to be four and if we add these
together to find a e that's going to be
12 but